Now let's take a look.
This was a potentially tricky quiz. Don't feel bad if you had a little trouble with it.
We want this pplus nonterminal to correspond to one or more Ps.
No matter which branch you take here, you're definitely getting at least one P,
but we need you to have the chance to get more.
This option, pplus goes to P, corresponds to picking just one.
Pplus goes to P followed by pplus--this recursive rewrite rule
Gives you the possibility to have as many as you want--possibly even infinite.
We've seen that before with expression goes to expression plus expression.
Over here, this i-question mark is supposed to relate to i-option.
One possibility is that you don’t want to write an i at all, but another possibility is that you do.
Here this question mark means have either 1 or 0,
this the rule for having 1, and this is the rule for having 0.
Some strings in this language or p, pi, ppi--that sort of thing.
In fact, if you have a bit of a musical theater bent,
you could imagine context-free grammars singing across to regular expressions
the classic line from Annie Get Your Gun,
"Anything you can do, I can do better. I can do anything better than you."
To which, classically, the opponent replies, "Can you bake a pie?" "No." "Neither can I."
But in fact, any regular expression relating to pi or something similar, as we've seen above,
can be handled both by our regular expression protagonist and our grammar protagonist.
Just a fun little interlude.